Let's talk about relationship properties.
Throughout this course so far,
every relationship example has been a one-to-many relationship,
with the one on the dimension side and the many on the fact side.
This is the relationship that you will use in almost every instance.
I might even go as far as to say that you're unlikely to need any of
the other relationship types if you're building
out your fact and dimension tables correctly.
That said, you do have some other options
beyond one-to-many when it comes to cardinality,
even if one-to-many is generally your best choice.
These include one-to-one and many-to-many.
Additionally, you can specify the direction that the relationship flows,
either going one way from the dimension to the facts or both ways.
So filters can go in either direction between the facts and dimensions.
Let's start with one-to-many.
One-to-many, with a single direction filter,
is the MVP of relationships.
In plain English, that means there's one value in a single table,
like the product dimension table on the left,
that's correlated to multiple values of another table,
like the sales fact table on the right.
It's reverse, the many-to-one means the same.
You just be starting with
the sales fact table and pointing it towards the product dimension table.
In general, you want the single value to be on
the dimension side and the many values to be on the fact side so that
all those good descriptive details can be listed just once and then
associated with as many transactions or facts as are relevant for reporting.
Let's make this concrete with a couple of examples.
Like I mentioned, on the left,
we have our product dimension table with each apple variety listed just once,
but the transaction sales listed many times on the transactions.
Here's Fuji apples, for example,
showing up once on the product dimension but multiple times on the sales fact table.
Then on the right,
we have our date dimension table with 1/31 listed just once,
but multiple times on the sales fact table.
Both of these constitute a one-to-many relationship.